all right so in this module we're going
to be talking about syntax of
propositional logic so if you remember
this diagram what we're going to be
talking about in this lecture is
thinking about syntax of logic thinking
about semantics of logic the meaning of
logic and in addition to that thinking
about inference rules how can we
manipulate logic and one point i want to
mention is like you might have seen
logic in other classes you might have
seen logical formulas and being able to
manipulate them and move things around
and and that's not really the point here
the point here is to have this general
framework kind of like this more
principle way of looking at logic where
we can think about algorithms that can
manipulate uh logical formulas and and
can do inference rules just more
generally from an algorithmic
perspective so the point is not for you
to be able to like do logic and move
things around the point is to have an
algorithm that that algorithm can can do
logic so because the goal of this class
is to have an artificial intelligence
that can do similar things as how humans
would do it so so the point is not for
you to do logic the point is for the ai
to be able to do logic and this is kind
of like an analogy to that is thinking
about the bayesian networks lecture
right like last week we talked about
bayesian networks and and in that
setting right like you might be able to
do conditional marginal probabilities
perfectly fine right you might be able
to manipulate things perfectly fine but
that was not the point the point was not
for you to do that the point was to have
an algorithm maybe like keep sampling
that is more generally can be applied to
any bayesian network not like a single
example so so we're basically trying to
do a similar thing in the space of logic
here okay
so let's talk about syntax so what is
syntax so the syntax of a propositional
logic consists of a few different things
so it consists of propositional symbols
so this could be like uh a or b or c
like these take boolean values and then
based on these propositionals of symbols
we can we can basically build formulas
on top of them the prepositional symbols
are also commonly like known as atomic
formulas and then you can make more
complicated formulas based on these
atomic formulas using a set of logical
connectives so these are negation and or
implication or bi-directional
implication
so let me actually write that here
so
here so we're going to start with syntax
so what does syntax have so syntax has
prepositional
formulas
propositional symbols sorry
so these are like a b
c and so on and then we can have
formulas
defined on top of them and let me use f
for formula and how do i define formulas
i use these logical connectives to to
create formulas these connectives that
we just talked about okay
so um like here are a couple of examples
of how we go about it so we can build
these formulas recursively let's call f
and g formulas here and if f and g are
formulas then i can even build more
formulas on top of them so i can have
negation of f as a new formula or f and
g as a new formula or f or g as a new
formula if implication g or f
bi-directional implication g so like f
is equivalent to g you can think of it
like that okay
here are a few examples so if a is is a
boolean symbol a is a formula by itself
negation of a is a formula
negation of b implying c is a formula so
i've just used a bunch of connectives
and created a more
complicated formula here
uh i can have this guy as a formula
right so negation of a is a formula
negation of b is a formula negation of b
implying c is a formula negation of b or
d is a formula and then or of these and
end of these is also going to be a
formula okay
negation of negation of a is a formula
well why is that because a is a formula
negation of a is a formula negation of
that is also formula
and this guy a negation b is not a
formula so why is that the case well
negation of b is a formula a is a
formula but a and negation of b are not
connected with each other using any any
logical connectives so so this is just
basically putting two two bullion
two formulas two logical formulas right
next to each other without any
connectives and then that's not a
formula
a plus b is not a formula well why is
that because plus just doesn't have any
meaning like it doesn't have like the
syntax of it is not defined here right
like i never defined plus and and that
doesn't have uh any that doesn't make
sense in this logic it's not defined in
this language okay
and whatever point i want to mention
here and we'll talk about semantics soon
is that syntax here you can think of it
just as symbols like syntax it doesn't
have any meanings right syntax is just
the symbols that we are using here and
and with no meanings assigned to it and
the job of semantics is to to assign
meanings to what does negation mean
actually or what does implication mean
and like what would be the meaning of it
but when we're talking about syntax i
could use any other symbol i can use
this symbol and and and i can just
define that in my logic and and that
would be the syntax of my logic so don't
assign any meanings just yet and when
you're talking about syntax it's just
symbol manipulation when we are talking
about syntax right
but next in the next module we're going
to talk about semantics and giving some
meanings
you